here's one half of London Jew
and host of the Netflix show trigger
warning Michael elendor aka killer Mike
is over here
[Applause]
all right Mike so glad you're here I'm
glad to be here are you representing now
this is man this is in master I know
we're gonna get around and talk about
capitalism some point well a couple kids
a big and tall Street where I ran called
gran so they're chubby
they figure chubby kids could buy
expensive shoes so I invested in their
company I bow so alright I got a million
things don't ask you let's just start
with jay-z because that's all in the
nose jay-z has partnered with the NFL
yes I understand Robert Kraft is the one
who brought them together
Robert couple years isn't that amazing
meek free got jerked off but the
Internet is on jay-z yeah like Beyonce
sister in an elevator because of course
if we had the Superbowl yeah and Colin
Kaepernick still doesn't have a job in
the NFL doesn't and there was a lot of
pressure from a lot of people saying you
artists you've maroon 5 played the gig
but they got [ __ ] for doing it
some people stayed away some people are
now saying that jay-z is giving NFL
cover evergreed he's a he's a Pro Bowler
for the panthenol of a player he said it
looks like your goal talking to jay-z
was to make millions by assisting the
NFL in burying Colin's career I don't
agree with that but I want your take
being a black American is a duality
right and I never gate it because I was
raised in Atlanta so in Atlanta Super
Bowl came last year I stood up in one of
the meetings and I raised hell about
there not being a social climate
involved meaning I said it at least you
could have 12 kids shadow producers and
learn how to produce a show we have our
Arts in theater school that out has came
out of Tri City my school Frederick
Douglass High School arts program I was
like simple as that you can do that
right I saw how our communities got
decimated when Major League Baseball
kind of pulled out years ago
they found another genetic pool down in
Dominican Republic they could get much
cheaper right
are we still talking about jay-z yeah
[Applause]
what fuels them right so the NFL is
fuelled by talent from black kids and
poor working-class white kids that make
good jay-z has been a capitalist his
entire career and celebrated one because
he was one of us that made it out the
streets made it in rooms and he did what
he could when he should when the Grammys
did not show the hip-hop portion jay-z
boycotted I know cuz I boycotted the
same year only grandma ever won I was
sad as hell laughter but I stood in
solidarity jay-z's play okay I believe
not only gives us a seat at the table
young people young like America it
doesn't destroy what cap kneel for what
he knit for was proper treatment of us
by state agents beliefs that does not
end with him getting the job the same
way him kneeling is not an insult to the
military it is as an American asserting
your First Amendment rights saying
something is wrong so on both sides of
this polarized issue that we're giving
to narrow these narrow issue these wide
issues and giving this narrow frame to
argue like Chomsky said we shouldn't do
that look for the tertiary agreements I
believe that if jay-z becomes his team
owner cap gets a tryout but the quote is
basically saying time to time for action
yes and to me it sounds like he's been
talking to Obama no jay-z has because
this is Obama to me well let's do
something real let's get something done
let's not let the perfect be the enemy
of the good the african-american
community where argue that Obama didn't
do that their elements the same elements
that would argue that jay-z's betraying
there's an element of African American
unity that's not very pleased with Obama
now I'm not here to castigate I'm just
helping saying we are not monolithic
monolith no we have different views and
around jay-z there was a mayor in
Atlanta named Maynard Jackson when he
took me Oreo ship this is what he said
we're going to have a seat at this table
so 29 percent of any contract that comes
across the city has to be African
American participated and owned he
couldn't find one African American
architecture front at that time so you
know what he did hire black contractors
to build a runways he said if you can
build a dry
but you can build a runway so although
he couldn't include us in architecture
he got black companies like the Herman
Russell company working to build Fulton
County Stadium to build a and that's
what Jay is doing and with that say it
ohyou support of captain alright
may I ask a second question you'll get
more questions okay so guns yes every
time you're here we have to talk about
guns because I don't know why not but
there was a shooting last week and Cory
Booker Kamala Harris have have gun plans
out and they're talking about these red
flag laws I bet you I know that you're
not down with that I can't be I'm an
african-american male I live in a
progressive city in the deep south I'm
surrounded by white gun owners who have
owned guns for generations who agree
with the president that's being compared
to nationalistic and naazy like I would
be a fool to then give my guns to said
government doesn't mean I have anything
personally against the lobby to get
Kamala and Cory in whether it be a
Senate seat or presidency it means that
I simply cannot in my support of black
participation in politics that is an
issue I cannot support because a red
flag means they're going to find reasons
to take I know you would say that
they're gonna find more reasons with
easy the gun laws affect African
Americans worse than first you know how
dr. King got guns to be an issue he
filed for a concealed carry permit you
know that in the deep south 7080 years
ago black men could buy shotguns they
could not buy rifles well what's the
difference they both kill people a
shotgun can kill the Klan once they're
thirty yards away a rifle could kill the
Klan at a hundred yards away I wouldn't
want a dead Klansmen 100 yards away so
that he never gets within 30 yards of
shooting my wife and children
[Applause]
and you know we already have my view too
many police you know there are five
police forces forces between Malibu and
this studio I haven't pulled over about
for them there's the FBI and the DEA and
the ATF and the TSA and ice and federal
yeah and Sheriff's Department and the
federal marshals and exhausting the cops
but you know that's a lot of people with
a license to kill who don't really share
my politics and they all love Trump
absolutely I can't say all but a lot
like I'll call me last week who's a
constitutionalist hot no love Trump he
voted Trump yeah okay so you're Atlanta
yeah there was a big Conclave today with
Mayor Pete was there yeah I'll be I'll
be very much there yeah oh you will be
there tomorrow I'll leave right after
here to fly home oh why it's not happy
about he wants to stay I'm a little
smoke weak
why would it be different in mouth yeah
we got better strip clubs you got better
wheat okay so mayor Pete yeah what do
you think about mayor Pete because I
every time I turn in the news they're
talking about him and they say well he's
got a problem you know he's not down
with the brown I like his personality I
don't know enough of his policy I know
he ran into some issues around the
police and sat in the South End area my
thing is with police forces in any mayor
why do they seem to have control and
volley over the mayor's office versus
the other way around now in my city
police seem to be taken to task more
right there were a group of policemen
who accidentally killed of like a black
old lady on a false premise drug raid
they were sent to jail policemen killed
the kid who was falsely accused still in
car went to jail that doesn't happen in
other places New York de Blasio could
have done something quicker he did not
so he showed his cowardice in Mayor
Pete's growth into a national policy
he's gonna have to get out in front of
this and be tough and square
Dick Gregory said something years ago
god bless today if you attack insurance
companies and police pensions you will
see a deceleration because he said it's
funny you never see black cops
accidentally keep killing white kids not
that they're more spiritual or smarter
they understand that white people are
not going to tolerate it and the way
that you don't tolerate things in
capitalism is attack the money if you're
police force it's miss abusing and using
you and they don't look like you find
ways to attack their money find ways to
attack the unions their pensions find
ways to attack the city's money and
you'll see change okay
you